now it's my pleasure to introduce Laurel
Traynor Laurel is a cognitive
neuroscientist and a senior fellow with
CFR's esri le program in brain mind and
consciousness she is director of the
live lab at McMaster University
you saw the live lab in the opening
sequence where members of the Gryphon
trio were hooked up to motion sensors
analyzing their movement to music Laurel
is an accomplished flute player herself
and she has devoted her career to
understanding the role of music in
development of cognition perception
communication and emotion she will talk
about the deep connections between music
and our sense of movement and community
even at the earliest stages in life
please join me in warmly welcoming
professor Trainor
it's wonderful to be here tonight with
all of you and I wanted to thank C for
the esri Ella foundation Michael Koerner
and the Royal Conservatory for their
support in this and of course it's been
a pleasure to work with the Griffin Trio
and putting this together did you know
that the average person spends about 13
years of their life just listening to
music music is found in every known
human culture past and present it has a
long history going back at least 30,000
years and today we spend a lot of time
and money on music in fact the u.s.
makes more money exporting music than
pharmaceuticals music has this
incredible ability to move us
emotionally it can uplift us with joy
and it can make us weep around the world
parents sing to their infants well they
hold them and rock them one interesting
thing about music is that it's usually a
social activity we make and listen to
music with other people and whether it's
musicians playing in an orchestra people
singing in church an audience clapping
or dancing to a band and even in the
modern world when we can listen to
recorded music alone by ourselves we
still feel connected with the musicians
who created that music and with other
people that we know also listen to that
music now because we make music together
we have to coordinate now when you talk
to someone you have a conversation
usually you take turns but in music we
have to play at the same time so these
musicians for example need to move their
bows at the same time which means that
to play together their brains have to
anticipate a
out of time what to play and they have
to anticipate exactly when to play it so
that they are together they also need to
coordinate their emotional expression so
they communicate with their audience if
they wait to hear what the other
musicians play it's too late in a way we
do the same thing when we move or dance
to music we need to predict when the
next beat is coming so that we get our
foot or other body part in the right
place at the right time it's interesting
that for the most part your brain does
all this prediction and coordination
without conscious awareness in fact it
can seem to be effortless so along with
my students
Andrew Chang Haley kragnes and Stephen
Livingston we were interested in how
musicians move in order to communicate
during a musical performance so as you
saw in the opening video we brought the
Griffin trio into the live lab at
McMaster University so the live lab is a
very unique space it's a beautiful
concert hall but at the same time it's a
research lab it has an active acoustic
system with 28 microphones and 76
loudspeakers and it can reproduce the
acoustics of a cathedral a subway
station or a fine concert hall in the
live lab we can measure heartbeats and
brain waves or EEG in multiple musicians
and audience members during actual
performances at the top of the slide
here you see an eg cap being placed on
an audience member and I'm going to talk
a little bit later about some of our
studies with EEG we can also measure how
people move in great detail using our
motion capture system as you saw in the
video we placed reflective markers on
Roman Anna Lee and Jamie as they played
our 24 special infrared cameras recorded
the positions of these markers and from
this information we constructed
three-dimensional models of their
movements so let's look a little bit
more detail at these movements so Jamie
here this is Jamie showing by these
pointlight markers to play the piano all
he needs to do really is move his
fingers at the right time push the keys
at the right time and similarly Annalee
here and Roman here all they need to do
is pull their bow across the strings at
the right time coordinated of course
with their left hand fingering now this
in itself is a very complex feet and
takes years of practice but to do this
they don't have to move the rest of
their bodies but they do move their
heads and they do sway their bodies when
they play so we measured and analyzed
these movements to see if they used them
to communicate emotion with each other
so the question was did they use
movements to convey a common emotional
expression so that they were not just
three musicians playing at the same time
but they were communicating the meaning
of the music so now I'm actually going
to play for you the video of them
playing oh tono porteño by asteroid
Piazzolla and these points here you
probably can tell these are their heads
these are the shoulders and their arms
this is the violin and this is the cello
so you see you can get quite a bit of
information just from their movements
next I'm going to play you two videos we
asked them to play during their trip to
the live lab the same piece twice so in
one version we asked them to play
without musical expression so that is
without emotion and in the other version
we asked them to play expressively
conveying the emotion of the piece
whatever it was I'm now going to show
you these
videos of the point light displays I've
taken out as you can see I've taken out
their lower arms and their instruments
so that really all you can see now is
their head movements and their body sway
now both of these versions the
expressive version and the non
expressive version will play at the same
time and I want you to see whether you
think version a at the top or version B
at the bottom is a version in which they
were playing expressively to communicate
the emotion just give you a heads up you
might want to look at Roman here when
the first time I met Roman he told me he
wears his emotion on his sleeve
so he might move more than the others
but also look at Jamie's head movements
they're quite interesting and look at
the way Anna Lee sways her body now
after you watch these we're going to ask
you to actually rate tell us which one
is the piece in which they were playing
expressively
ok so now it's time to take out those
clickers that you were given when you
entered the auditorium and if you think
the expressive version was the top one
press a on your clicker if you think the
expressive version was the bottom one
press B on your clicker okay so let's
let's see how you responded whoa you
guys are good
so you see without even hearing the
music you can tell how expressively
they're playing just from their body
movements now I'm going to play you two
more videos and this time we ask them to
play some pieces that expressed a happy
emotion and some pieces that expressed a
sad emotion and I want you to decide is
the top one or the bottom one playing
the happy emotion okay here we go
okay let's see these results whoa
exactly the same I don't know what that
means so the important thing here is
that it was pretty easy for you to tell
just from their movements without any
sound when they were playing a happy
piece and when they were playing a sad
piece now I trust that I have made you
anticipate how these pieces actually
sound for long enough so now we have the
treat of actually hearing the griffon
trio play these two pieces
so the next question we asked about
their movements was when they play
expressively and they are actually are
they actually communicating better with
each other then when they play non
expressively so we analyze this using a
technique called Granger causality so
represented here on the x-axis is time
and represented here on the y-axis is
the body's way of musician one and the
body's way of musician two now here's
the key with Granger causality if we
take a particular point in time say here
what we want to know is can we predict
the movements of musician two from the
prior movements of musician one over and
above any prediction we can do within a
musician if we can if the movements of
musician one here predict time musician
two is going to move here then that
tells us that they are communicating
through their movements we can look at
how much each musicians body sway
effects or predicts each other
resistance body sway so for example how
well does the violinists predict the
movements of the cellist how well does a
cellist predict the movements of the
violinist and we can take the sum of all
six of these relationships and this
tells us how well the musicians are
communicating as a group and we call
this group coupling so here we compare
the expressive and the non expressive
performances of these pieces and here we
did it for all the happy pieces and you
can see that the expressive pieces in
yellow have greater group coupling than
the non expressive pieces that are shown
in white same thing is true for the sad
pieces again you see that the group
coupling was higher when they played
expressively than when they played non
expressive
so these results tell us that body sway
is actually helping them to communicate
emotional information to each other
about how to play the piece and it's
affecting how the piece unfolds in time
so body movements communicate emotion
when the trio played did you find
yourself tapping your foot or at least
you might have felt an urge to do that
next I'd like to talk a little bit more
about why rhythms are so powerful and
how the brain processes rhythms rhythms
occur in music of course but they occur
in many biological systems so we walk
rhythmically speech has a rhythm our
heart beats arrhythmia
one of the most important things about
rhythms is that they are predictable
when the notes are spaced evenly in time
like this you can predict with very high
accuracy when the next beat is going to
occur so rhythms are incredibly useful
because knowing when something is going
to occur allows you to focus your
attention at that point in time and this
allows you to be prepared for what is
going to happen at that point in time in
fact we can think about the brain as an
organ that is always trying to predict
the future through evolution this was
incredibly important to survive for
example you needed to be able to predict
what direction a lion was going to go in
and when it would reach you to make sure
that you would not be at that place at
that time now today if you're a team
sports player it isn't enough to know
where the other players are now you need
to know where they're going to be a few
moments from now this is Russell
Westbrook he plays now for Oklahoma City
and he's one of the main reasons why
they did so well this year here he is
when he was
playing college basketball for UCLA his
teammate here has the ball he is trying
to pass the ball to someone who can get
closer to the net so he might predict
that Russell is going to move in here
and Russell might predict that if he
starts moving here he will throw him the
ball if this guy on the other team
doesn't also predict that he's going to
get scored on so to play basketball you
need to be able to dribble and pass and
shoot but one of the most important
things is to be able to predict where
the other players are going to be and be
in the right place at the right time
music makes use of our ability to
predict the future rhythms and music
shown by the musical notes in yellow
here set up expectations that the most
important notes are going to occur on
strong beats and our attention goes up
and down with the rhythm of the music so
for example if musicians god forbid
played a wrong note you would be much
better able to detect that if the wrong
note was on a strong beat then if the
wrong note was played on a weak beat and
the quartet is just going to illustrate
this for us they're going to play a
little excerpt from hiding and see if
you hear a wrong note in what they play
okay I think you heard that they're now
gonna play a wrong note but it's not
going to be on a strong beat
did you hear that
very subtle yeah
so this waxing and waning of attention
that set up by rhythms is very important
now how does our brain do this
well neurons in the brain communicate
with each other through electrical
signals when a group of neurons
depolarize and fire together they create
an electrical field that we can measure
at the surface of the head and this is
called the electroencephalogram or EEG
now we can take a recording of EEG like
the one that's shown here and we can use
Fourier analysis to decompose it into a
series of oscillations so you see slow
oscillations here or low frequency
oscillations medium ones here and fast
or high frequency oscillations here and
these different oscillations actually
reflect very important brain processes
so what does this have to do with rhythm
well in our research we've shown that
when a person listens to a musical beat
some of these brain oscillations in
trained or synchronized to the beat so
the brain is a bit like a resonator the
neural oscillations in your brain line
up with the rhythm of the musical input
so what you see here are actual brain
responses to a series of equally spaced
beats and these were measured by takako
Fujioka who is by postdoc at the time so
the musical beats are shown here this is
what the person actually heard and you
can see they're evenly spaced in time
the x axis represents time and on the
y-axis we have low frequencies here
going up to higher frequencies here now
the colors represent energy so red
represents a lot of energy
and blue represents very low energy and
so what you can see is that after a beat
if we look at these middle frequencies
here around 20 Hertz after a beat
there's a decrease in energy decrease in
this oscillation and then it rebounds so
that it reaches a maximum at the time of
the next beat and then we get another
decrease after that beat and again it
rebounds so it reaches a maximum at the
time of the next beat this is the brain
predicting when the next beat is going
to occur if we slow down the tempo so
now you see these beats are spaced
further in time the brain responses also
slow down so we still get the decrease
in increased decrease in increase but
it's now entrained to this slower tempo
so this is the brain predicting when the
next beat will occur and this is what
the brains of musicians are doing when
they are playing it's what enables them
to play together and this is also what
your brain is doing when you listen to
music your brain in trains to the beat
even when you're just listening and
you're not playing music and you're not
even moving your brain is predicting
when the next beat is going to occur now
it's interesting that this anticipation
of prediction of the beat occurs in your
brain without you even being aware of it
you're not conscious of it and remember
this because in the second half Robert
is going to talk about how these
expectations actually affect your
emotional responses to music now we can
actually look across the whole brain and
we can look at which areas of the brain
show this entrainment to the beat well
not too surprisingly we see it in
auditory cortex and that's the part of
the brain that processes sound but we
also see it in the supplementary motor
area and in the cerebellum these are
parts of
the brain that have to do with movement
nothing to do really with hearing but
this is why when you listen to music
with a beat you feel an urge to move
whether tapping your toe or breakdancing
even if you don't actually move the
motor circuits in your brain are
preparing you to move to the beat so
again we see this very powerful
connection between auditory rhythms and
movements now movements are very
important in another way
musical rhythms set up social dynamics
if two or more people listen to the same
music and they all move to that music
they're going to move at the same tempo
this has important social consequences
because when two people move in
synchrony afterwards they feel more
socially affiliated have you ever
wondered why we have music at virtually
every occasion when we want to feel
common emotion with others we have music
at weddings to feel joy together we have
music at funerals to feel grief together
we have music at religious ceremonies
and at parties we have music and
rhythmic chants at sporting events to
feel one with other fans and we have
music in the military to promote
solidarity so experiments have found for
example that if two adults move in
synchrony with each other afterwards
they cooperate more with each other they
trust each other more and they like each
other more in comparison to people who
move out of sync with each other again
for the most part were not consciously
aware that synchronous movement has
these effects on us but they can be
quite powerful so how early in
development
can we see pro-social effects of
movement synchronization well to
anticipate
the answer is we can see them very early
now the motor system of infants is very
immature at birth it takes months before
an infant can even sit up or roll over
so for the most part infants are not
able to precisely move in time to a beat
so to test whether synchronous movements
with another person affect their social
behavior another graduate student of
mine Laura Cirelli and I decided that we
would move infants so specifically we
bounced them here is our experimental
setup this is a 14 month old infant and
this assistant here is holding the
infant and the infant is listening to
twist and shout by the Beatles and this
assistant is the bouncer so she bounces
up and down and bounces the infant up
and down in time to the music this is
the experimenter she faces the infant
and she bounces according to whatever
she hears over her headphones and
sometimes her beat track makes her in
sync with an infant but for another
infant she might be out of sync with
that infant and bounce either too fast
or too slow after this experience we
then see how willing these infants are
to help this experimenter that they
either bounced in sync with or out of
sync with so in this first video you
will see an infant being bounced in sync
with the experimenter so let's take a
look
so in the second video you're now going
to see whether that infant who bounced
in sync with the experimenter helped the
experimenter in our tasks Oh
Oh
No
Oh
there
okay in this next video you're going to
see an infant bounce out of sync with
the experimenter and now see whether
this infant helps the experimenter we
learned was that those infants who were
bounced in sync with the experimenter
for just two and a half minutes helped
her much more than those infants who
were bounced out of sync the power of
music so in a second study we examined
whether infants who were best in sync
with one person would help a stranger
who just sat here and didn't bounce with
them and the answer was no they didn't
infants don't help strangers who don't
bounce with them
but in another condition the infant
bounced still with just the one
experimenter but the infants also saw a
skit where this experimenter interacted
with this stranger so that it was clear
that they were friends and in this case
the infants did help friends of NSYNC
bouncers so this is pretty sophisticated
infants are using their knowledge of
social relationships and using cues of
music to decide on their social behavior
so around the world caregivers sing to
infants and rock them to sleep and
bounce them to play with them we now
know that infants use rhythm as a
powerful cue to navigate their social
worlds and decide who to trust and who
to befriend so let me sum up music makes
us feel emotions much of the power of
music to move us results from the
predictions that music sets up these
predictions enable us to move in time to
music and to play in sync with other
people and moving together can
strengthen bonds and increase
cooperation and altruistic behavior so
these research findings also have
important clinical applications for
example music can be used to help
mothers with postpartum depression to
bond with their infants training with
musical rhythms can help children with
dyslexia and moving to music can help
Parkinson's patients to walk and now we
will end the first half with you having
the privilege of feeling the rhythm and
feeling the emotion and perhaps feeling
some affiliation with your neighbors
while the Griffin trio plays the second
movement of Lalo's piano trio
number three
you